mais que se passe-t-il
comment font-ils des géants semblant
venir du net
des armes avec une facilité
déconcertante les leaders traditionnels
de toutes les industries
une par une douleur vient une telle
puissance et surtout est-ce que je peux
m'en saisir moi citoyen pour mon
bien-être
laissez-moi vous emmener au delà de
l'économie matérielle des échanges de
biens et d'argent en tant qu'être humain
nos interactions en trois dimensions
premièrement la connaissance qu'on
utilise pour décrire le monde qui nous
entoure
deuxièmement la confiance qui
lorsqu'elle se multiplient devient
réputation et troisièmement les émotions
de toutes les sortes connaissance
confiance émotions
ces échanges sont bien embarrassant pour
cette science de la rareté qu'on appelle
l'économie
déjà ils ne sont pas mesurables est ce
que vous dites j'ai 13,37 de confiance
dans mon médecin et six équipes au si
c'est pour qu'il vous réparer votre
voiture ça sera sûrement autre chose
ensuite ils sont abondants
lorsque je vous partage une connaissance
je ne l'oublient pas je n'ai pas besoin
d'enlever ma confiance dans l'isabelle
pour la donner stéphanie et enfin ils
sont un permanent voyez ce cadre serait
table gels abandonne ici que je reviens
demain il sera toujours là toujours le
même mais vous si vous êtes de bonne
humeur et que je vous en faire 24 heures
dans le noir
serez vous toujours de bonne humeur faye
et jongler avec connaissance confiance
et émotion c'est un exercice délicat
alors pendant des années on a essayé de
les cacher de les négliger
on a défini dans nos vies une sorte de
deux bus une parenthèse appelé vie
professionnelle dans laquelle ils
n'étaient pas les bienvenus il n'est pas
professionnel de pleurer au bureau on ne
se fait pas confiance on signe des
contrats à la place etc des corporations
employant des milliers de salariés sont
venus remplacer les petits artisans et
les commerçants locaux
le libraire de mon quartier qui me
reconnaissais et me conseillait dans sa
charmante petite boutique pleine
d'émotions et de sentiments a été
optimisé sauf que sauf que dans le monde
qui vient l'information et liquides
elle voyage à l'autre bout du monde sans
frottement se fractionne en toute petite
goutte et protéiforme s'adapte pour
épouser au mieux les contours de chaque
récipient c'est à dire de chaque cerveau
livrés au bon format au bon moment au
bon endroit
et ça c'est une révolution
l'information liquide rend le monde
transparent transportés par les
technologies numériques connaissance
confiance et émotions deviennent
observable toujours pas mesurable certes
mais on peut les capter conserver leur
empreinte les développer toutes les
plates formes qui émerge s'applique à
cela avec un milliard et demi
d'utilisateurs le plus grand réseau
social du monde n'est que cela on y
brasse en permanence des connaissances
que nous publions en y associant nos
émotions avec des smileys et puis la
confiance exprime avec des laïcs des
commentaires des partages ah si quand
même
il ya aussi des flux hybride cette
accumulation gigantesque d' échanges non
marchands se convertit en flux
financiers au travers de commissions sur
des transactions
big data machine learning réseaux de
neurones
voilà les noms des outils qu'on utilise
pour manipuler les trois flux non
marchand ils servent en fait à
interpréter la myriade de signaux
faibles que sont nos interactions
quotidiennes avec notre environnement
notre entourage au sens large
non pas juste les 150 personnes avec qui
nous avons une relation consciente mais
bien les 100000 dont nous n'avons
parfois même pas idée de l'existence
ce voisin qui achètent comme moi c'est
indigne et qu'ici la même pétition que
moi tout ce que l'on appelle nos liens
faibles dans chaque plate forme à
laquelle nous avons souscrit
nous avons un alter ego virtuel un
modèle numérique de nous mêmes de qui
nous sommes et leur manipulation confère
aux quelques individus à la tête de ces
plateformes un pouvoir incommensurable
et ça ça fait peur
c'est bon vous avez peur là beaucoup de
technophobes refuse tout net d'accepter
cette évolution continue ont parfois de
penser que facebook n'est qu'un jouet
dangereux aujourd'hui je vous invite à
explorer une autre piste et si l'on
pouvait chacun d'entre nous reprendre
notre part de cette puissance reprendre
le contrôle de notre alter ego virtuel
pour le mettre au service de notre
liberté
à quoi ressemblerait le monde si on
laissait librement et pleinement
s'exprimer dans nos vies connaissance
confiance et émotion pour les mettre en
prise avec nos cinq mille liens faibles
il est probable que l'impact le
contraste le plus marquant se verra à
l'échelle des grandes entreprises
prenons par exemple le cas d'un
organigramme pyramidale dans une
démarche centrée sur l'humain je ne suis
pas aux ordres exclusif d'une seule
personne
je suis en fait la réalité de toutes les
organisations et que je suis en fait
sous l'influencé cumulé de toutes les
personnes qui comptent pour moi
soit parce que je les fréquente beaucoup
soit parce que je les admire et qu'elles
sont un modèle pour moi et en mettant
l'intensité de ses liens de confiance
personnelle en pleine transparence on
obtient un système suiveurs suivi un
image de twitter qui se représente par
un graphe social
chaque point est un individu et chaque
flèche est une influence mais allons
plus loin que deviendraient les
entreprises dans un monde où confiance
connaissance émotion est pleinement
repris droit de cité quelle force peut
amener des personnes libres à se
regrouper pour exécuter la vision d'un
entrepreneur un idéal un idéal noble
transparence oblige les entreprises
deviendraient des
club ouvert d'hommes et de femmes unies
par les causes qu'ils partagent et
d'autres besoins de réalisation de soi
passant par la satisfaction d'être utile
au monde
en servant ses causes de son mieux alors
m le profit au service de sa pérennité
vendant des causes lieu de vendre des
produits maximiser son impact sociétal
rêves néo hippies ou réalité économique
du 21ème siècle bien venez donc nous
voir au vietnam et on vous montrera car
tout ceci n'est pas une fiction
en 2006 nous sommes partis au vietnam
fonder une société de services
numériques offshore
l'objectif à l'origine était de bâtir
âgées en vietnamien de la technologie
pour contribuer au développement du pays
mais aussi avons le pour jouir de la
liberté de ne plus avoir à répondre à un
chef
sauf qu'en 2012 le bât blesse déjà
certains clients se révèle être pire que
les pires des chefs
mais surtout nous prenons conscience que
nous avons formés en dessous de nous une
pyramide de 200 vietnamien qui eux
avaient tous un chef 200 personnes dont
les libertés étaient sacrifiés pour
notre indépendance et qu'au final nous
n'avions même pas nous en avions même de
moins en moins à mesure que la structure
grossissait il était temps de tout
remettre à plat et d'en profiter pour
intégrer les trois flux non marchand et
l'information liquide au coeur de notre
gouvernance
l'organisation qui en a résulté
aujourd'hui n'a plus de
dh n'a plus de commerciaux n'a plus de
chef
elle regroupe en fait trois cents
individus libres salariés et
responsables
le rôle que nous demandent de tenir le
monde professionnel nous éloigne trop de
qui nous sommes intimement pour vous
protéger contre cette tension
schizophrène osé accueillir pleinement
dans votre travail
les trois flux non marchand connaissance
confiance et émotion forme d'un filtre
très utile même si parfois un peu
inconfortable pour éclairer vos
décisions
tenez penser à une étape clé de votre
vie un déménagement des missions un
changement de poste
repenser à ce tournant à ses
conséquences et utilisons ensemble le
filtre le prisme des trois flux non
marchand connaissance
qu'avez vous découvert depuis cette
décision et qu'avez vous fait découvrir
à d'autres confiance vous sentez-vous
maintenant prêts à prendre plus de
risques
émotion pouvez-vous maintenant plus
facilement accueillir les émotions
qu'ils viennent sans vous il n'y a pas
de réponse unique
il n'y a pas de réponse quantifier il
vous faut aller trouver en vous votre
propre réponse et l'assumé dans toute sa
subjectivité embrasser les trois flûtes
en marchant c'est accepter de s'exposer
au risque de la critique des autres sans
pouvoir se défendre par un argumentaire
rationnelle sans pouvoir se baser sur
les conventions de la société de
consommation c'est passé pour un
excentrique parfois même pour un
égocentrique
nous trouverons la paix quand nous
serons naviguer sur cette fine ligne de
l' équilibre entre qui nous sommes
intérieurement et notre harmonie
nécessaire avec la société
embrasser sa vulnérabilité c'est aussi
en prendre soin confier la à ceux qui
vous aiment trouver ceux et celles avec
qui vous oserez vous mettre à nu dans le
creux de leur main et qui auront
l'empathie et la bienveillance de vous
aimer inconditionnellement
peut-être est-il là le secret de l'amour